The Joe Rogan experience,
the war on drugs is destroyed.
Our inner cities,
it's corrupted the police forces.
It's screwed up,
uh,
you know,
a police,
uh,
south of the border and now you have a situation to where your inner city kid
and you know,
you've got minimum wage laws and you've got occupational licensing laws that
make it almost impossible for young kid to get a legitimate job yet you've got
the gang bangers flashing around,
you know,
a lot of cash.
Hey,
just deal drugs.
You can make a lot of
when you think that minimum wage and the difficulty in getting licensed for
certain positions are what's keeping people down.
Of course,
minimum wages.
Keeping people down.
Absolutely.
How is that?
How's that?
Well,
because remember,
you know,
when you're young,
when you're teenager,
right?
You don't have a lot of skills.
I mean,
you really,
you might've never had been had a job.
And what's more important in getting a job is not necessarily the paycheck.
That's kind of secondary.
It's what you learn on the job.
And you know,
when I had my first jobs and I was working on me,
you know,
you're living in talking about outside of high school or in high school,
the all that's important is the money's the only thing that's important to know
when we,
when,
when you are,
look,
you want the money,
right?
Because you want money for,
to take a girl out on a date or maybe you need gas money,
right?
But you don't need rent money.
You're living at home,
you don't need food.
Your,
your overhead is taking care of.
The real benefit is acquiring skills on the job training that will enable you to
earn more money as you get older and take on more work
responsibility in these skills.
When you're working at Burger joint.
What am I.
What skills am I getting?
Working at Newport creamer?
No,
no,
there are a lot.
Like,
I'll give you an example of gas stations because gas stations are good examples.
I worked at a gas station because at one point in time there were a lot of jobs
for young kids,
uh,
gas stations and,
and,
and they work mainly for tips.
They would pump gas,
they would check the air in the tires,
they'd wash your windows and they didn't make very much,
but between Philips and these were the pump jockeys,
right between Phillips,
maybe they worked with a mechanic and they helped out to mechanics and you know,
a lot of auto mechanics got their start as a pump jockeys and you know,
and you know,
eventually,
you know,
they were able to become a mechanic and they can earn more money as some of them
may be eventually opened up their own gas station and you know,
became entrepreneurs and had a few,
but they got started,
uh,
you know,
at an entry level position.
Now of course,
the minimum wage law,
it's all self serve.
I mean,
you go to a gas station,
there's no human beings there.
Maybe there's one guy that's in a little booth that's kind of overseeing,
but you know,
if you want to check your air in your tire,
you do yourself.
You want to wash your windows,
you wash her own windows.
All those jobs had been eliminated by the minimum wage.
But so as the opportunities that came with them and now if you want to get a
mechanical,
you've got to go to vocational school,
you got to pay money,
you got to go into debt,
you know,
maybe you can learn to be a mechanic.
But you know,
on the job training was how young people use to acquire skills.
And now we've got all those guys going to college.
They get a philosophy degree,
you know,
they spent six years,
barfing at frat parties,
but they graduate with a huge debt.
They know nothing,
you know,
a lot of them would have been better off getting,
getting a low paying job and learning how to do something.
This
time of this,
when people did learn how to be a mechanic by becoming a pump jockey,
there was a minimum wage in effect.
Well,
the minimum wage in America didn't start until 1938.
But I looked at a gas station,
but I had a minimum wage.
It started in 1938 and it only affected some certain federal workers.
It wasn't.
And it was 20,
it was,
was it five slash twenty five cents an hour.
It didn't apply to most workers until the mid 19 sixties.
So it was the war on poverty that really brought about the,
um,
the minimum wage.
So,
and,
and of course over time,
as the minimum wage got higher and higher during the sixties and seventies,
that's when it really began to take a bigger toll.
But at,
like if you look now at like black teenage unemployment,
which is off the charts,
which is what 50,
60,
70 percent of sure example it is.
But if you go back before the minimum wage,
right?
Black teenage unemployment was made out of 15 percent.
It was actually lower than white teenage unemployment.
Um,
and,
and all this stuff you take,
you take the bottom rung off the job ladder and you just obliterate it.
Used to make it impossible for young,
unskilled people to get a job.
And it's not just a minimum wage because that's the beginning,
right?
Because if you employ somebody at the minimum wage,
you still got to pay payroll taxes.
You got to pay unemployment taxes.
You've got other mandated costs,
legal costs that increased the cost of hiring.
So maybe even though the minimum wage is seven,
25 an hour,
maybe it cost you 10 bucks to hire the guy an hour even though you only give
them seven,
25 is cost you 10 bucks.
What if,
what if their productivity is only worth $6?
You can't hire him.
It's impossible.
You're not going to hire him to lose money.
You're not going to train somebody.
I mean,
you know,
there are a lot of people,
these success stories,
you know,
people go from the mail room to the board room,
it's harder to start at the bottom because it's hard to get your foot on the
bottom right because,
you know,
you have to be at a much higher level and it disproportionately impacts poor
kids.
Inner City kids,
uh,
you know,
and,
and it favors these minimum wage laws will favor skilled workers over unskilled
workers.
Because if I have to pay a certain wage,
well then maybe I'll hire somebody that has more skill.
In fact,
it was the skilled workers,
the labor unions that lobbied for the minimum wage,
not because it benefited them because they,
they made much more than minimum wage.
What they wanted to do is make it expensive to hire unskilled labor.
So you wouldn't hire the unskilled labor.
You would just hire the union labor.
I see what you're saying.
So you're saying essentially is that minimum wage is more government intrusion
and the more freedom that you have the government take away from you,
whether it's minimum wage freedom,
whether it's tax free and whatever it is.
The worst is gonna be you're gonna have more regulations,
you're gonna have more people involved,
more red tape,
more bullshit,
and more waste more.
I should have a right to work,
you know,
if you know,
if I want to write it,
you know,
if you know the interesting thing,
look at all these lawsuits now.
The internships in the entertainment industry,
you know,
this has the perverse effect of it.
So the government made it illegal to pay somebody below the minimum wage,
but it was okay if they worked for free.
Right?
So now you have all these interns who probably would have been paid something if
it wasn't for the minimum wage,
but since it was illegal to pay them something,
they ended up working for nothing.
Of course,
now they're suing and they're winning lawsuits say,
hey,
you have to pay me.
So now they're going to destroy the internships and now a lot of these companies
that used to have internships aren't going to have them anymore about the
interns get college credit.
It wasn't that the whole idea behind it.
Some of them do,
but then.
But then that was even worse because what would happen sometimes in order to
keep themselves safe because the employers didn't want to know,
run a foul of the employment law.
So they would only give you the internship if you got it through a college.
Right.
So now what would happen is you'd actually have to pay to be an intern because
you'd go and pay tuition to a college just so you can go and work for free.
I mean,
wouldn't it be better not to pay the tuition and go into debt and just work for
a low wage than to pay to work for no age?
I mean,
this is what happens when you have all these government regulations.
Everybody is worse off and you know,
people,
people think,
oh,
these young people are being exploited.
No,
they're not.
It's not exploitation in.
A lot of times it's the best thing that can happen to them is they get a job and
you know,
people say,
well,
you know,
you can't raise a family on the minimum wage.
Of course not,
and you shouldn't even try.
I mean,
if all you can do is flip burgers,
why are you starting a family?
I mean you should,
you know,
you,
you got to develop your skills.
You got to be able to earn more money than that before you take on those extra
responsibilities.
But if you say,
hey,
every wage has to be a wage that could let you know,
support a family,
then there are no entry level jobs.
Well then how do you enter the labor market if there's no entry level position,
you know,
well,
if you're in a situation like a fast food Gig,
what,
where does that lead to the manager?
I mean,
what,
what are you going to rise through the ranks at a fast food?
Some people write,
some people start out,
you know,
uh,
cooking French fries or mopping up and,
and go onto b if own a franchise.
I mean,
so you can certainly move up and there are people,
uh,
I think the guy who's about to be the new CEO of Walmart,
his first job was working on a loading dock and what are the distribution
centers?
And now he's the abuse.
The CEO,
he worked his way up to the very top of the call.
He went to college.
Uh,
but I mean,
that's not,
but that's not what,
how he got his foot in the door and I don't,
I probably,
you know,
but,
but the,
I mean,
they wouldn't have hired him to run the company and let's say,
but I don't know,
but maybe,
maybe,
maybe the fact that he worked there,
gave maybe that game,
a legacy assure that definitely had an impact.
But if you take a look at something that works at Mcdonald's,
you don't necessarily have to work up the chain of Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's could be your first job.
Look,
what were my first jobs?
I delivered groceries.
I bagged groceries.
I,
um,
I sold a clothing retail in the mall.
I sold shoes.
I sold cable door to door.
They said,
well,
you know,
did I move up in the.
And.
No,
but I,
I ended up getting other jobs where,
you know,
the sales skills were important.
Uh,
you know,
even when I was,
got my first job at a supermarket and a lot of times I was just mopping up the
floors.
I was bagging the groceries that I would deliver the groceries.
But you just learn to show up at time,
you know,
and now you have something that you've done.
I mean a lot of it.
So you get a job at Mcdonald's and then you get a job someplace else.
That's better because what,
what did you do before you were here?
While I worked at Mcdonald's.
How long were you there?
I was there for a couple of years.
In fact,
I still have the job.
Oh well that means at least you didn't get fired.
You have the job.
I mean you've got something.
You've got to start somewhere.
Everybody starts somewhere and you can't expect to get paid a lot of money when
you first start out.
You've got to make yourself more valuable because what you are when individuals,
we sell our labor to the highest bidder,
you know?
And so what you have to do is you've got to figure out how can I increase my
value to a potential employer so that he'll pay me more money but isn't the idea
of minimum wage just to keep it from being gross,
not just make it.
So it is $15 an hour is pretty low.
It's incredibly difficult to make a living.
No,
no,
no.
It's getting $15 an hour.
But I'm going say you don't have to make a living and feed yourself if,
if,
if they,
if they enforced a minimum wage of $15 an hour on like Mcdonald's,
there would be no human beings working there.
It would all be automated.
They wouldn't,
you know,
there might be one guy there that made sure that the robots didn't,
uh,
you know,
didn't break down.
But you know,
there'd be machines making the hamburgers,
make it a French fries would be like a gas station.
Wouldn't that be good?
Just like we were talking about deregulation and the government forcing them to
get real jobs for the people that work in the fast food,
Burger King and forced them out there.
No,
but then they would,
what would they do that and just go on welfare for them to figure out a way to
get a real job.
But no,
but that is their entry to the job market.
I mean,
they have no skills.
Look,
believe me,
if these people had better skills,
would they be working at Mcdonald's?
Now,
part of the problem is,
and this isn't,
you know that there are some people that really could be working better jobs,
but they're not because we have this phony economy that is preventing those
better jobs from being created.
That's the.
That's the problem.
There are a lot of people now that are working at Mcdonald's because that's all
they can get and you know,
it's not like you know,
at least they got that to fall back on,
but the problem is why aren't there better jobs?
Why aren't the jobs that would normally be there for you to work up right?
To the jobs that are higher up on the ladder.
Where are those jobs?
Those jobs are being destroyed by the government because we need more savings.
We need more capital investment.
We need higher interest rates for that to happen and the government is so busy
inflating this bubble economy that they're sucking all the air out of the real
economy.
They're diverting resources from main street to Wall Street and they are
preventing these jobs from being created,
in fact,
are destroying a lot of the jobs that exist.
So how would you fix that if you.
If I'm Obama and I say Peter Schiff,
I heard you on the Joe Rogan experience.
You make a lot of sense soon guys.
I got working me.
Fucking suck.
Come over here man.
Sit down.
Tell me what the fuck to do.
What can I do here?
How do we fix this mess other than resigning,
but I guess if he's,
if he's actually going to listen to it and make friends,
but if he's actually going to listen to me that I don't want him to resign with.
He actually has that kind of epiphany.
Let's pretend well attend Jamie's the president and you've got to convince him.
Yeah,
well then you,
she got a.
What would you tell them to do?
What would you tell him to do?
He's got to start repealing rules and regulations and,
and,
and shrinking government and closing down agencies and departments and laying
off government workers,
government workers.
How do you.
Where do you start?
I'll start at the top.
I mean,
we've got to fire the president.
Do you want to save the company?
You got to go under yourself.
Get rid of all of the economic advisors.
Look at the Department of Energy,
Department of Agriculture,
Department of Education schools.
Every one of them.
Some of them are,
some of them aren't,
but we can't afford them and they're not helping.
They're not making the country richer.
They're making it poor.